- I started singing, and you should see
the people who are running
the audition's faces.
One woman gasped, she held
her mouth, they could,
their faces, they could not
hide their disappointment
in how terrible I was.
(upbeat rock music)
I am in studio, in L.A.
Tom Thakkar is holding down the fort
in New York with Ian Fidance.
- How is your butt hole?
But in a caring way.
- (laughs) Yas, queen.
- Yeah, it's doing
great, thank you so much.
- So good to hear.
- It feels good this morning.
- Good.
- Feels good most mornings.
I can't remember the last time
my butt hole didn't feel great.
- I'm so jealous.
- But thanks for asking, Ian.
- Yeah, I'm very jealous.
Good for you, yeah.
- Really?
You know what, let me introduce our guest
for this hour of the show.
(laughing)
I am so excited and proud
to introduce my friend,
my dance partner, I never
thought I would say those words.
My dance partner, Gleb
Sevchenko, everyone.
- Woo!
- Yeah!
- This is Ian and Tom,
look at them.
- Hey guys, good morning.
- How's it going, pal?
- What's up, Gleb?
- Great.
- Oh, goddamnit, guys.
- Whoa!
- [Nikki] We're really doing it,
I don't know what's
happening with this story.
- This camera's flying around.
- We are doing it.
- Is there a drone
flying around the studio?
- I know, right?
- We're in it to win it.
- Are we in it to win it--
- Yes, we are.
- Gleb?
Okay--
- I can't wait.
- Yeah, you're--
- Come on!
- You're hilarious, that's
not what you said when we were
on the press line yesterday--
- Oh shit, what did you say,
Gleb?
- At Planet Hollywood
in New York.
- Oh, Gleb,
you son of a bitch.
- What'd you say?
No, you know--
- This is the gotcha show.
- I was like she's great,
she's great. (laughs)
- He just goes, she's--
- She looks like a dancer
when she don't move.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- (laughs) She's so cute
when she's sleeping.
(laughter)
- Yeah, that's exactly
the vibe that we have.
It's yeah, I do better
when I'm just standing.
I can really hit a pose, I
can really strike a pose.
There are times when Gleb
will position my body
in the way that it's supposed to be,
and he's like, "See, this is it!
"This is it!"
And I'll be like I feel like
my organs are shutting down
from this position.
Like I will be so twisted and I'm like,
how am I supposed to find
that, he'll be like that line.
Those lines are great.
I'm like, that's not a line.
I have scoliosis now from
what you're doing to me.
It has been so much fun with this guy,
you watch this show,
Dancing with the Stars.
Gleb has been on it,
what number season is
this for you as a pro?
- Nine.
- Wow.
- Nine seasons, yeah.
- You've done nine seasons
as a pro?
- Don't hurt him.
- But I've done it in different countries.
- Different countries, yeah, I mean,
they told me yesterday
there were 52 countries
where they do Dancing with the Stars.
- Wow.
- 52!
- Yeah, that's wild.
- Isn't that insane?
So Gleb has done many
different versions worldwide
but he's been on the American version
for how many seasons now, as a pro?
- Since season 16.
- Since season 16,
and now we're in season 27.
So Gleb is--
- Yeah, well,
I missed a couple of them, so.
- Yeah, he was in and out,
he was traveling, and--
- Total, it was like eight or nine.
- Wow.
- Yeah, so you've worked with
eight or nine celebrities at this point,
stars, and trained them.
I mean, you see it on the show,
and I never really watched
the show but I would always,
you hear sound bytes, you hear celebrities
talk about their experience on the show.
And they always say like
their partners and them become so close,
and it's so, you spend
so much time together,
you go yeah, yeah, yeah,
I mean, Gleb is now one of my best friends
because I dance with him everyday.
It's such an intimate relationship,
I know that I'll know this
man for the rest of my life,
which is weird, I told him the other day
we're gonna be at each other's funerals.
One of us is gonna go
to each other's funeral.
Isn't that a weird
thing to say to someone?
But it's true for most of
the people in your life.
- I'm gonna die with you.
(laughter)
- Yeah, or we'll
die together, Gleb.
- Oh yeah, get people
plots together.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, that's great.
What's a great idea?
God.
- Gleb, we have a contract
for you to sign, to agree to.
(laughter)
- But Gleb is someone that
I, when I did my research,
when I knew I was gonna do this show,
and I was looking at all the dancers,
I was like, who do I want?
And he was like my number one pick
and then I walked into
the room to meet him,
and I was so excited.
- No, it was awesome,
yeah, it was awesome.
The first day when we met, I was like
oh my God, I'm gonna dance with this girl.
And we did a little twirl, remember?
Like I turned you under
the arm, and you were like,
I was like, oh my God, I got so excited
until the first rehearsal.
- Until. (laughs)
- And then it kind of--
- Oh, Gleb.
- Damn, Gleb!
- [Nikki] No, that's a real thing, like.
- No, but then now we're like 10 days in,
and now I'm actually excited
for this performance.
- I know, Gleb--
- I think we would kill it.
- Gleb took a shift the other day,
we've been through some big ups and downs.
It did not start great, but
it was still early enough
that I wasn't getting totally discouraged.
- So how do you feel now?
Tell me, like I wanna know.
- Okay, so glad I practiced last night.
'Cause I didn't wanna disappoint you today
because our last rehearsal,
you were a little bit,
we just both get frustrated
that my body doesn't
do what my mind knows.
(laughter)
What I've done over, like
I will do a dance move
that we will perfect, I'll
do it like 50 times, right?
Like he'll drill me so
that it's muscle memory.
And then we turn on the music
and I completely forget it.
And he had to leave the room the other day
'cause he was so frustrated
and I was frustrated with myself.
I just fall to the ground, I go no!
Because it's like we just did this.
I mean, I have never been
on that side of things
where I'm teaching someone
something and they have it
and they get it and
you're so proud of them
and then they lose it,
as if they never knew it.
But it must be frustrating.
- I mean, it's hard to move to the music.
- It is.
- If you've never
done it before, it's hard.
- I know.
- But it's possible.
- Yeah.
- And you're gonna be great.
- I've already done things
that I didn't think I could do.
I watched the video we
record ourselves at rehearsal
and then I watched it
back, and I was watching,
I was watching it in slow mo last night
and really going over it and
then practicing it a lot.
Here's how I feel, Gleb, to be honest.
I got in a wormhole yesterday,
Gleb and I were both on the same flight,
and he was sitting next to Vivica A. Fox,
I was sitting next to some guy,
who was like just some
guy, I don't even know.
But and I got into a Dancing
with the Stars wormhole,
and I watched too many
videos, and I got in my head.
- Oh no!
- And I watched
Zendaya too much, which you
were in one of her dances,
the salsa with Zendaya.
- Yeah, that was the salsa.
- If I danced the rest of my life,
every day, trained like an Olympian,
I would never even be able to
do one-tenth of that dance.
I mean, she was so perfect.
I mean, and you were,
that was a fun dance,
right?
- It was fun, yeah.
- That was so, it was so good,
and that's the problem, is like
I can't be watching these other videos.
I have to just like be
competing against myself,
I have to compare
myself to myself.
- Exactly, don't compare
yourself to anybody, just
compare yourself to yourself.
And try to be better
than you were yesterday.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, I don't know
that I am better than I was yesterday.
Like I think I--
- Well, if you look at the
first video we shot at the
beginning of rehearsals
when we just met, and when you look at
the video now from yesterday,
it's totally different thing.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- You do see improvement?
- You're like, you are
a dancer, remember your homework?
You have to look in the
mirror every morning
and say to yourself, I am a dancer.
- Yeah, Gleb gives me homework.
- Yes, I do that every morning.
- Gleb really had a powerful
moment with me the other day
where he's like, and it
was real, you were mad.
And I liked it because the
other day, you snapped into,
we have a lot of fun, Gleb
is a really fun funny guy.
And we joke a lot, and we
get a lot of work done,
but we have moments of like,
when I mess up, we joke about it.
But the other day, you were frustrated
and I could tell that you came
in with a different attitude
of like, I'm gonna work this bitch today.
Like we were doing
cardio, we were sweating.
And you had a moment
later on in the rehearsal,
where you were like
you are a funny person,
but you are not a, he would like,
he said the greatest quote, he was like,
"You do jokes, but you are not a joke.
"You're not a joke,
Nikki, you're not a joke.
"You are a Victoria's Secret supermodel,"
which is secretly what I always wanna be,
so you really nailed it.
He was like you are like
on the runway, super sexy,
you have to be sexy, and
I just never have felt,
this is a challenge for
me, is to be sexy and to,
I can act sexy, like I can
act it, but to actually be it
and believe it, is a
totally different thing.
So I'm really trying,
like when I do my makeup,
I put on my music and I just
dance around like a real slut.
Like I just am trying to be,
(laughter)
I'm trying to just be a slut,
I'm trying to ooze
sexuality wherever I go.
I want everyone wanting
to fuck me wherever I go
because that's like, I
need to get in that mindset
for this dance of being really powerful,
really sexy, and not
goofy because it's so easy
for me to make a goofy face or make a
goofy movement.
- We could dance to
one of the Kanye's new song.
- Kanye's, which one?
Oh yeah, that one.
- You're such a dirty--
- Oh yeah, it's about
such a dirty slut.
- I love it, yeah. (laughs)
- Yes, Gleb--
- Wait, it's a Kanye song?
- Yeah, there's a,
what is it, Kanye and who?
- Kanye and,
what's his name?
- Oh, I don't know
if I've heard this.
- Yeah, oh my God--
- Gleb just said it was
Kanye and Lil something.
- You should listen to it.
(laughter)
- Thanks for being specific.
But yeah,
it's so hard, and I still have to
learn another dance before
what?
- Lil Pump,
it's next to Lil Pump.
- Who's Lil Pump?
- Lil Pump.
- Who's making these
dances up?
- Gleb.
- Oh, I don't know this.
- Gleb?
- Gleb is, you don't understand
what these guys do.
- Gleb's making them up?
- He choreographs the dances,
he has to teach them to me,
and literally it's really
hard to teach someone
who's never done a thing
when you're the best at it in the world.
I mean, Gleb has been
dancing since he was seven,
he is one of the best
dancers in the world.
He is a world champion,
I mean it's just true.
You are, you're like a--
- Well, I've never won
a world championship
but yeah, I'm great.
- But you've gone to
world championships.
- I'm really awesome.
- You've gotten really close,
and you would have won them
had you been in the
right country to win them
because there's a lot of politics
going on in the world of dancing.
Gleb literally is respected
as one of the best
dancers in the world, I know that.
And on the show, he just,
he stands out, like even amongst everyone,
no offense to the other dancers,
but your eye is drawn to
Gleb when he's dancing,
he just has a style that is very,
I don't even know anything
about dancing and I'm like
there's something special
going on with that guy.
And but he, it's really times
that they choreograph it, he
comes up with the concept,
he has a whole creative vision
for it, and the other day,
it was so weird, we were doing the dance,
and there's a part of
the dance where I step,
I see him and I'm like hey you, what's up?
And then I kinda walk away
from him 'cause I'm like,
I'm done with you.
And then I take two steps,
and then I go wait a second,
I wanna go back to him.
And he's telling me, he's like Nikki,
so the dance is, you walk
away and then you turn around
and you come back and you realize
no, I'm not done with him.
And I'm like do you know my life?
This dance, he's choreographed
a dance that is my love life,
of just like going away, coming back,
going away, coming back.
- Did you just try to put on the
Russian accent a little bit?
- Yes, I tried to put on a Russian accent.
Gleb, yeah, I mean, you
have a Russian accent.
I know you wanna lose it,
but it is very strong.
And it's good though, I don't
think you should lose it.
- Yeah, I'm gonna keep it.
I wanna be able to,
(laughter)
I wanna be able to keep
it but if I want to,
just get rid of it so no one
knows that I'm from Russia.
- Can you try to do the
most American accent
you can do?
- The most American
accent, like you speak now.
- Whoa.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Say something, you say something.
- Okay, Gleb, I can't dance.
- Gleb, I can't dance.
- [Nikki] That's pretty good.
(laughter)
That's pretty good.
- It sounds like Tommy
from the Disaster Artist.
(laughs)
- Yeah, it really does, kind of.
But Gleb, your story
is really fascinating.
You're a hot guy who a lot
of people can write off
as like oh, he's just like
a hot dancer, hot dude.
I could write you off that way,
and I will continue to
write you off that way,
but I also do know the truth about you,
which is like you, what got into dancing?
I find your story kind of fascinating.
You grew up in Moscow.
- My grandmother--
- Right?
- My grandmother,
so what happened, yeah,
I grew up in Moscow,
I was seven years old,
I really liked a girl
in my class, we were in one class.
And she joined dancing
and I asked my grandma to
go and sign me up, which is I
just wanted to see her more.
- The girl?
- The girl.
And that's how I started and then,
eventually I started dancing with her
and then she quit dancing
because her parents moved and then--
- But didn't you, you
were in this dance class,
and people who go to dance
classes to scout talent
stop by and you were just in this,
and they were like that guy has it.
- Yeah, there was like a
local small competition
where judges from the whole
town came in to judge.
And one judge came up
to my parents and said
this guy got talent, why don't you kind of
push a little harder
and have private lessons
and just more training?
That's what my parents did,
and that's how I got into it.
And then I never stopped.
- Yeah, and--
- Where's the girl now?
- And at what,
yeah, where is she now?
- Yeah, no.
- No.
- The girl was dance the entire time.
(laughter)
She was dance.
- She was dance. (laughs)
So, where did you,
so I like the turn in the story
where you were dancing in Russia
and then you got to a
place where you were great.
I mean, how old, you were 14?
- Yes, so what happened, I
was dancing, dancing, dancing.
We won a lot of competitions,
I had, I don't know, 10,
12 different partners
every single, like every half year,
I don't know why I was changing partners.
By the age of 14--
- Sounds like a sex life.
- I knew I was good.
(laughter)
Yeah. (laughs)
By the age of 14, I knew
it was gonna be my career.
- Yeah, wow, that's early.
- Yeah, but it was hard, like in Russia,
it's hard with everything,
the mentality of the parents is that
if you do something, you
gotta be great at it.
Otherwise, there's no point
invest money and time into it.
And if you don't do it right
now, and you don't deliver it,
they're not gonna do it anymore.
That's what my parents'
mentality was like this,
and if we do it, it's not just a hobby,
it's 100% your career.
And it's in everything, like
people play hockey or dancing
or soccer or anything else.
So and they push, push, push,
till the point where they reach like
we have to pay for private lessons,
we have to afford dance clothes and shoes.
Everything was really expensive,
it was brought from overseas
because nothing's been produced in Russia.
At that time, it was
like, what, 25 years ago.
And we were dancing, we
were on a good level,
but there was no way that I wanted to--
- How much dancing were you doing
when you would go to school,
and you would go right
to dancing afterwards?
- Right, exactly.
- Did you do
three hours everyday after school?
- Like three, four.
- Wow.
- Yeah, three, four hours.
Yeah, with a partner and whenever we can,
we go and travel to maybe
different towns to compete
and do all those local competitions.
And we were at that point, we were like
top five in Russia, at
the Russian championship,
but at that point, I
understand there's no way,
even if I'll be the greatest dancer,
better than everybody else,
I'll be number one or two
to be able to go to the world championship
to represent the country.
- So to represent Russia, you
would have to be one or two.
- Yeah, top two couples
represent the country.
- And to be in that position,
you would need to have a lot of money
to get--
- Yeah, you have to have
a lot of money--
- The best clothes, the best
training, the best travel,
everything.
- Exactly, exactly.
- So you saw, you go, I wanna compete on
a world level and for me to do that,
I'd have to be two of the best,
which I probably am skill wise, but--
- So my teacher, yeah, my
teacher came up to me and said,
listen, you gotta just change
the country of representation.
You have to go somewhere else,
and just represent that
country to be able to go
to the world championship
and you can win the world
championship and everybody's
gonna know about you.
But you have to be one of second,
first or second place.
So I thought about it, and it was like,
where's the closest place on the map?
And I just like, Latvia,
Lithuania, Estonia, Finland,
it's everything like all around Russia.
It was just overnight train ride.
So I just got a visa to Lithuania,
and I went to Lithuania 'cause
my teacher's wife lived there
and kind of like knew the whole scene.
And I was just--
- Yeah, you really
go there to find a girl.
- To find a girl, yeah.
- To find a partner.
- And you were how old?
- I was 15.
- So you were 15,
and you took a train to Lithuania
to go find, to go meet
a potential partner.
And you get there, and what is that like?
Do you go on a date?
Do you just meet in the dance studio
and then just start dancing?
What's the--
- No, I remember I was in,
so I got there, I took a bus.
I had the address, so I took a bus
to the place where that coach lived.
And I was just sleeping in one room,
she put me in there for two nights.
And then we just went to the dance studio
and she had a few girls
that I tried out with.
And then there was a
competition the next day,
and I saw this girl, she
was really, really good.
I was like I wanna dance with her.
She goes there is no way you'll
be able to dance with her
'cause she, they're number one in here
in Lithuania.
- She already has a partner.
And I didn't dance with
her, so it was like I left.
And then I told my dad
like, I need another $300
to go to Latvia 'cause there's
another girl waiting for me.
My dad like, "Are you crazy?
"What are you doing?
"You're 15 years old, you
better go and study and do
"something that is eventually
gonna make you money."
I was like, "No, I wanna dance."
So I went to Latvia, and
then I went to Estonia,
and then I went back to Lithuania.
And I was just, I spent
probably like eight months
traveling around Europe
just trying out with all
these different girls.
And then it was just, I lost all hope.
I was one day in Moscow, just
sitting there and be like,
I don't know, I'm just
gonna continue dance here
and find another girl here.
And then I got a phone call
from parents of this girl
that I tried out from
Latvia and they were like,
"Listen, I think it's gonna work.
"You just gotta figure
out how you're gonna come
"and live here, like how
are you gonna support."
I was like, "Don't worry
about it, I got this,"
which in my head, I was like
uh, I don't really feel like,
there's no way.
- Yes, that really gives me a lot of hope
when you go, we got this.
You tell me we got this all the time,
and now I know what
you're really thinking,
it's like we'll find a way.
You say we've got this to me so often
and now I know what that really means,
which is it's 14 year
old Gleb being like uh.
- So to make a story short,
I went there, start dancing with her,
won all the championships,
and then we went to Lithuania,
that was a funny thing.
It was an open Lithuanian
championship, we went there,
and we won, we got first place,
and that girl who didn't
wanna dance with me,
the girl, she got second.
- Yes, yes!
- Hell yeah, Gleb.
- Got her ass.
- Now, Gleb--
- You got Glebbed.
- When you were picking
a dance partner, does it
always come down to skill,
or when you're a 14 year old pubescent boy
who's like, is there any
part of you that's like
yeah, she's great, but
then there's this girl
that's a little less
great, but she's super hot?
I wanna dance with her.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Does that play into it at all?
'Cause honestly--
- A little bit.
- When you dance with
someone, there's gonna be a,
you're gonna be, especially at that age,
hormones are raging, you're gonna end up
hooking up with that person probably,
at that age, if you're both
single, young adolescent kids.
- Well, the thing is, when
I danced with that girl,
we didn't hook up.
- Oh, wow.
- She wasn't really hot,
but she was a great dancer.
- She was a great dancer, yeah.
- She wasn't hot.
- You weren't attracted
to her, right, yeah.
And then you won all--
- I could, but I just didn't.
- Yeah, yeah, you could.
Oh, listen, Gleb,
(laughter)
we know you can.
It was totally on the table,
so she was into you, but
you were not feeling it.
Yeah, yeah, where is she now?
- She's in Latvia, we're
still kind of attached.
- Still deeply in love with you.
- Okay, that's nice.
So then, I wanna get to
when you came to America,
like how did you first get here?
And why were you coming here?
Oh, I wanna talk about where you got this,
so you were like down and out,
you were out of money and then
an opportunity came into your
lap, which was your face.
- Yeah, well, it was like,
thanks a lot, yeah,
so I danced with a girl and
then we danced for two years.
I fell in love, I fell in
love with another girl,
I broke up with her--
- You were about to go to
world championships with one partner,
and then you fell in
love with another dancer,
who was not as skilled.
You switched partners right before
the world championship, right?
- Yes.
- And you did not win.
- No.
- Because your partner sucked.
- Yeah.
- But she was super hot--
- She was super hot.
- And you guys were banging, yeah.
Okay, so then you lost
the world championships.
- I lost everything.
- All this practice,
you lost everything.
- I pretty much lost
everything, yeah, I came back to Moscow
and I said to my dad, I was like,
"What am I supposed to do?"
He was like, "Well, you really screwed up,
"like you go and figure it out yourself."
So I had no money, I had pretty
much like no place to live.
- How old were you at this point?
- I was 19, 18, yeah, 19.
Yeah, and I started working
at the fitness center,
doing some salsa classes.
And this girl, again, another girl
came up to me and she goes,
"Listen, have you ever tried modeling?"
I was like, "Modeling, I
mean, sure, let's try it."
So she took me to this model agency
and it took off.
I became like one of the top models,
I'd done a whole bunch
of different commercials.
- In Russia, you were like--
- In Russia, I was like--
- The guy.
- Yeah.
Like Gigi Hadid here,
you know what I mean?
- Yes, in Russia.
- Like in Russia, yeah.
- And then--
- And then it was like it's too small,
I better go and explore,
like I gotta go to America.
- Yeah, big in Russia,
but I wanna be big elsewhere.
- Exactly.
- And you had bigger dreams,
and you wanted to dance still.
I mean, did you think about modeling,
were you like oh, that's
just gonna be my career now?
Was there any part of you that said
I'll leave dancing behind?
- No, dancing was always,
'cause it was like, I've
danced for so many years,
and dancing was always my
life, so I could easily
go and teach and make some money
that I can pursue some other career,
you know what I mean?
That's what I wanted to do.
- So modeling
was your side gig.
- And that's what I did
in America, yes.
- So we're gonna get to
Gleb coming to America
after the next break because he's famous
in Russia at this point as a model.
His face is everywhere,
he's in every print thing,
he's on commercials, you're
making lots of money.
And then you decide to go to America.
And things take a turn,
and we'll get to that when we get back.
I'm in studio in Los Angeles
with my dance partner
on Dancing with the Stars, season 27,
which premieres September 24th, live.
We're gonna be dancing live!
- We're gonna be dancing live salsa.
- What happens if I fall, Gleb?
- Just own it,
own that fall.
- The music keeps going and
then I stand up and I take-
- And that's it--
- It from wherever we were.
- It will be great TV.
- Yeah, I know.
I'm kind of hoping for a fall.
(laughter)
- It's gonna go viral.
- Yeah, I know.
- The epic fall.
- Oh my God, I was watching yesterday,
I said I got into a wormhole of watching
Dancing with the Stars
stuff and like, yeah, fails.
And there haven't been that many,
there's been like one
girl who forgot her moves.
I forget who it was but what's been the,
since you've been on the show,
what's been like the craziest thing
that's happened live in your experience?
- Craziest thing is
when someone has a cramp
and you can't really move.
- Oh my God.
- Kirstie Alley,
she had that with Max
when they did a rumba,
and Max had a cramp on
his leg, and he could not,
like they were doing this, like a,
not a lift, but he was
dipping her somewhere,
and he had a cramp on the
leg, and he was like, oh!
Like starts shaking--
- Oh man.
- And he had to raise the hand to like,
they almost stopped the music
and he just kind of pushed
through, continue it.
But it was pretty bad.
- Wow.
- But things like, for example,
you're doing a lift and
the lift doesn't work,
and you're like, she's about to fall,
and there's like oh my God,
it's like when we did a
free style with Jenna,
I was so sick, I was so
exhausted, I was just so tired.
And we had this lift where
she jumps on my shoulders
and I have to like catch her
and start running forward.
So I start, like I don't
know what happened,
but I started running
forward, and I almost fell.
I thought I'm like falling--
- 'Cause you were just sick.
- I'm just falling, yeah.
Yeah, moments like that,
but everything else is fine.
- What's your favorite
part of the live show?
I mean, the dancing is where you probably
feel the best.
- It's just the excitement
in the studio, like all these
people are watching you.
And they're all so excited,
you just feel the energy.
- It's 1,000 people, right?
Isn't it a big, big crowd?
I mean, for a live television taping,
1,000 people is a huge crowd.
It looks a lot smaller than that on TV.
And then not to mention
the 13 to 18 million people
who watch it every week--
- Exactly.
- Watching at home, and then voting,
which you have to vote for me and Gleb
to keep us in the competition,
so please set your DVRs for
September 24th and 25th.
We will be dancing, we
will need your votes.
Team Gleb Glaze is what I'm calling us,
hashtag Gleb Glaze,
G-L-E-B, Glaze, G-L-A-Z-E.
I mean, yeah, I guess my biggest fear is
just fucking up and then
realizing I fucked up
and then fucking up more.
And then it just spirals out of control.
- Well, you gotta put,
you gotta catch yourself,
even if you make a mistake,
you have to kinda go back
and keep it together.
Don't let it, because they
don't know your steps,
they don't know your routine.
It's only me and you who knows this.
And even if you make a little mistake,
just keep going, keep pushing through,
and make sure you don't
show it on your face.
And just kind of like
fake it until you make it.
You know what I mean?
- Yes, what are you bad at, Gleb?
- What I'm bad at?
- Yeah, what are you--
- I can't sing.
- You can't sing.
Would you ever do a
Singing with the Stars?
- Singing with the Stars, sure.
- You would?
- I would do it.
- Gleb, I have to say, recently,
I think two weeks ago,
won Farming with the Stars
in the UK.
- Yeah, Celebs on the Farm.
- What?
- Celebs on the Farm,
it's called Celebs on the Farm,
and it's literally a farming show.
Gleb is a bona fide celebrity in the UK.
He has a number two selling calendar.
- Yes, number three.
- Number three selling
calendar right behind One Direction and?
- David Beckham.
- And David Beckham.
- Wow.
- Gleb Savchenko
is number three.
I can't wait to get this calendar--
- Where're you in there, Ian?
- Are you gonna come up
with a 2019?
- It's already out.
It's on the way here.
- Wait, it's on the way?
- Yeah.
- Here?
- Yes.
- To the studio right now?
- Not to the studio
right now, but. (laughs)
- Will you give me one?
- Of course.
- And Gleb also has a line of underwear.
- What can't Gleb do?
- Which you said
you were gonna give me 'cause
I ran out of underwear.
I only brought so many.
- Today, today, today.
- Will you seriously bring me some?
- Yes, I always forget.
- Every single pair is designed
based on a dance style.
So I want the salsa kind.
- Yeah, you got it.
- Okay, the chunky salsa kind.
(laughter)
- Do you have a dougie kind?
- I remember that dance.
- Oh yeah, the dougie.
(laughs)
Yeah, so Gleb, let's
go back to your story.
You end up in America, how?
'Cause you had bigger aspirations.
You were modeling in Russia.
- So I was modeling in Russia.
- You were in music videos,
you were in print ads,
you were in commercials.
- Yeah, everywhere.
- You were everywhere.
- Everywhere.
- You had the world at your fingertips,
you could have anything you want,
you were a single guy,
you were slaying it.
- Oh my God, it was the best time ever.
- Oh my God, was it the best?
- The best.
- I mean, you were partying all the time,
drinking like a true Russian.
- Oh my God, yes.
- You said that the other day,
we were talking about
hangovers and you were like,
oh, man, I was invincible
when I was that age.
- I could literally go for
two days without sleep,
wake up in the morning, go to work,
come back, repeat it again
and just do it like for three, four days.
Now if I have one or two drinks,
the next morning I'm like
oh my God, I can't wake up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so
you moved to America.
- I moved to America, moved to Brooklyn.
- You moved to Brooklyn.
- Yeah, to become like a
word famous model, male model.
Yeah, and that was like nothing happened.
I was just going from casting to casting,
audition to audition--
- Yeah, I got that market
covered, baby.
- And it was just
nothing happened.
So I was like I ran out of money,
I start teaching at local dance studio
in New York in the city,
and I was just doing
it, and then I started
hosting this little Russian
TV program called Time Out
for the Russian community
where we just take interviews
from all those different famous people
and checking out what's
happening in the city
to kind of let the Russian community
what's actually happening.
'Cause you don't realize
that, but a lot of people who
back in the day, moved
from Ukraine or Russia
to America and they moved to Brooklyn,
some of them, not even
been in the city ever.
So it's like their own world in Brooklyn,
they live there, and nothing's happening.
- Yeah, they don't go outside of
that area at all, yes.
- They don't go out, exactly.
So we were trying to go
around and just kind of like
talk about and let them
know what's happening.
- So you hosted that show.
- Hosted that show, nothing
happened, nothing happened,
and I went back to dancing,
I started competing again.
And I left, I left New York,
went back to Moscow and went to Hong Kong.
- Yeah.
- Got invited--
- 'Cause there was money to be made
in Hong Kong teaching, right?
- Exactly, teaching, start dancing.
- The Japanese wanna learn how to dance.
- Chinese.
- Chinese,
Hong Kong is in China.
(laughter)
Oh my God, literally just learned
that Hong Kong is in China.
(upbeat rock music)